on fait un reportage sur l'étrave estime
aujourd'hui il y en a pas un
donc on vous demande de jouer le jeu
pour que nous on ramène des images ce
qu'on a alloué une équipe ça coûte très
cher donc vous faites le tri vastine
minutes je vous pose trois questions
ok 1 quand vous appelez votre prénom
eric eric je vous appeler eric thomas un
manteau voilà qu'on va aller très très
vite vous et vous à faire partir un
personne venir
[Musique]
voilà temps des fameux la bouche données
voilà encore un peu wallard patron la
perruque
voilà ferme également donner votre
hockey erika vous vendez votre corps
depuis combien d'années 6 mois vous fait
combien vous fait combien de clients par
jour
oh ça dépend ça dépend quand il fait
beau je me fais au moins dix clients
vous prenez combien par client 300
francs par client je crois savoir que
votre spécialité et la brouette
togolaise alors en quoi consiste la
brouette togolaise la boulette togolaise
sait si vous voulez avoir les quatre
pattes en l'air
et puis sifflante par s'éprendre pas
derrière vous avez des gens de de la
politique qui viennent vous voir et a
très souvent les gens du show business a
très souvent qui par exemple et non de
ce côté là aussi je préfère ne pas dire
isolement
je remercie erika je voulais c'est
travailler votre visage sur un noir on
ne sait pas qui vous êtes mais c'est
nous des pales parce qu'il n'y avait pas
du tout de travestis et nous on n'a plus
une équipe et on va se faire virer si on
ramène pas d'image vous comprenez 1
alors je vous mets juste un collier
[Musique]
jacqueline vous
on l'a fait jacqueline vous vous
prostituées depuis combien d'années
maintenant
il vous fait le trottoir
j'ai pas vraiment une première main donc
vous prenez combien de payer en argent
ne savait pas c'est tout merci beaucoup
jacqueline laissez-le parce que avec ce
que vous trimballez là c'est pas venez
[Musique]
marie ghislaine vous vendez votre corps
depuis combien d'années maintenant
depuis deux ans je crois savoir que vous
avez une spécialité ça c'est à vous
c'est le chariot tournant alors combien
vous prenez pour cette spécialité dans
les 300 francs et vous fait combien de
clients par jour
non disent comment s'appelle votre
meilleur client mon meilleur client je
demande pas de renom d'ici tout à
l'heure que thierry ardisson
venez vous voir tous les jours c'est
vrai ouais c'est vrai qu'est-ce qu'il
vous demande tient à 10 ans d'un mandat
sujet et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le leader des tubes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu ce bleu